stoner comedy for the holidays I've
liked it before
hopefully I'll like it again the night
before so the night before is a stoner
comedy I want to call it a stoner comedy
but really Seth Rogen's the only one in
this movie that really gets high but
they try to score weed throughout the
movie said yes doner comedy star Seth
Rogen Anthony Mackie and Joseph
gordon-levitt they're a group of friends
they have a tradition on Christmas they
go around New York and they do a series
of events and things Anthony Mackie and
Seth Rogen at this point in their lives
are like we're kind of over this
tradition but Joseph gordon-levitt is
like well it's tradition we have to do
it so this is their last year doing this
and they did have fun in this movie I
enjoyed the second half of this movie
more than I enjoyed the first half of
this movie
the bummer of a STONER holiday comedy or
a STONER comedy in general is generally
speaking it's been done we have seen it
people have landed on this Plymouth Rock
before but you can't really deny the fun
you're having I first of all I love the
group of friends I love their chemistry
everyone in this movie had great
chemistry
I bought them as friends Seth Rogen was
a bit cartoonish but he's on mushrooms
and weed Molly and a hundred other
things there's kind of his role in the
movie he's like hey I'm gonna be the
target audience for this movie on screen
for them to relate there and oh my god
this movie has the greatest cameo ever
by the perfect actor to play this
character and the perfect character to
be I don't even want to ruin it for her
I don't want to tell you what actor
plays the Cameo but I'm just saying it's
perfect it's beautiful now the thing
that keeps a movie like this with this
premise fresh are the pop-culture
references because time changes so the
references will change this movie has
pop-culture references more in the
second half then the first half which
might be why I felt the second half was
a little more enjoyable because the
second half felt new now the thing that
brought this movie home for me and saved
the movie for me was also completely
unexpected and that is a very touching
story about friendship in here this
movie deep down at its core is a very
touching story about friendship and how
friendships they evolve and they change
throughout time and you shouldn't hold
on to the past you should roll with it
because that evolution of friendship
doesn't make the friendship any less
relevant or any less strong in fact it
does make it stronger so it was a really
cool lesson throughout this movie in a
very relevant one the funniest scene in
this movie was the church scene with
Seth Rogen but you saw that in the
trailer and that really compromised it
for me and I was
laughing in that scene it was a funny
scene I can only imagine how hard I
would have laughed if I had not even
known anything about that scene because
of the trailer I hate it when trailers
do that when they show the funniest
scene in the movie guys in the end the
night before is by and large what you
expect from a movie like the night
before some of the jokes were hitting
this and you can argue that most of the
jokes hit just not as hard as the movie
wanted them to hit but the heartfelt
message about friendship in this movie I
felt was really touching they really
brought it home for me and I will say
the night before is a good time no
alcohol or anything else required it's
really funny because as I'm filming this
Harold and Kumar Christmas and this
movie third right neck and neck on
Rotten Tomatoes that's going to be my
question for you the night before or
Harold and Kumar Christmas which one do
you prefer whatever you like comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more